welcome back Linux Enthusiast whether
you are a beginner or looking to refresh
your skills today's video is packed with
invaluable knowledge we are diving into
50 Linux commands that are absolute must
NOS for anyone using this powerful
operating system so let's get started
just a quick info for you if you want to
upskill yourself master cyber security
skills and land your dream job or grow
in your career then you must must
explore simply learns cohort of various
cyber Security Programs simply learn
offers various certification and
postgraduate programs in collaboration
with some of the world's leading
universities like MIT I kpur EC Council
and many more through our courses you
will gain knowledge and work ready
expertise in skills like Advanced
hacking Concepts Network packet analysis
ethical hacking network security and
over a dozen others and that's not all
you also get the opportunity to work on
multiple projects and learn from
industry experts working in Top Tire
product and security companies and
academicians from top universities after
completing these courses thousands of
Learners have transitioned into cyber
security role as a fresher or move on to
higher paying job and profile if you are
passionate about making your career in
this field then make sure to check out
the link in the pin comment and
description box to find a cyber security
program that fits your experience and
areas of Interest so now let's get
started and the first thing we have to
do is open the terminal so we'll just
press contr alt T and here's a terminal
and we'll get started with the commands
now so the First Command we'll see here
is
LS so what does Ls do it list all the
files and directories in the current
directory so as you can see we are on
the home screen only so it has listed
all them that is desktop documents
downloads music pictures public snap
templates and videos
as you could see uh so this is the home
screen and these are the directories
that are listed in the home and that
this LS command has provided all the
directories here and I'm running the
ento on the virtual box for your
information so if you have the window
install on your system so it's well and
good and I was using Windows so I use
the virtual box to install the one2 and
here we are running all the commands
and if you use LS minus Al so it will
give all the hidden directories also
hidden stuff so these are the hidden
stuff that was there so it has listed
them also so now moving on to the next
command that would be
PWD and what does the PWD command do it
prints the current working directory
where we are working so
PWD so we are at home abisara so this is
our current working directory and now
we'll see the next command that is CD
and what does it does is change the
directory if you want to move to any
directory you can just write CD and the
name of the directory and we'll see
which one we will go to
documents we'll just write
documents and press enter so now we are
in the documents
directory and with the command CD dot
dot we'll jump back to the previous
directory
that is CD space dot dot oh sorry now
you have been reded to the previous
directory that is home only and if you
want to just get back to home you can
just write CD space and click on you'll
get back to the home as we are already
on the home so we have not changed any
directory and the next command would be
mkd that is to create a new directory so
for that we'll just write mkd and the
name of the new directory what you want
to create so I will create the new
directory with the name abisal so we
have created the new directory you can
check here that abar that has been
created and if you want to remove that
directory you just have to use the
command rmd space abar and press enter
and that active would be removed from
there that has been removed and now
we'll see the command to create a file
and this is the easiest way to create
any file so we'll just use the touch
command that is to create a file and
after touch you just have to write the
name of the file so I'll write abar do
txt so you'll see so the txt file has
been created here so here we have
cleared the terminal and now we'll see
another command to create a file that is
cat so just write cat greater than
symbol and the name of the file that
would be a Bart 2 do
txt okay and press enter and now you can
write the content you want to insert in
this file so I'll write my name is
abar
and today I'm
creating a video on Linux
okay and after writing this you just
have to press controll and D so this
will be inserted into your file so after
pressing the control+
D this content has been inserted so we
can just check
it you can see here that the content is
already been inserted in the file
okay so moving
back now we'll see the next command that
is Echo and Echo is mainly used to get
get something to display in the terminal
only or you just want to talk to
yourself you can use the echo command so
here I'll write echo in inverted commas
I will write simply
learn and press enter you could see that
it has return return simply learn so it
get backs the text or anything you want
to display on the terminal only and now
we will see another command that is CP
and that is used to copy files or
directories
so here we'll use the command CP and
here we'll copy a file that is uh abis
2.txt into documents so for that we'll
write CP after that the name of the file
that is abar 2 do
kxt and then the folder name that was
documents and then enter now we'll check
in the documents we have
2.txt file and that has been copied into
that and the next command is MV so if
you want to move any file into any
directory you just write
MV and we have the file that is abhr TT
this file we will also move into
documents so we'll just write the name
of the file that
is Sir doxt
andt and the name of thep Dory in which
you want to move it so that is documents
Flash and then enter and now we'll check
it so you can see that it has been moved
so it has been moved from home to
documents and now uh we'll see another
command that is RM that is to remove any
file or
directories so from the documents only
we'll remove the file aisar 2.txt
okay so here we'll write
rmr2 do
txt
and from where you want to remove it
that is
documents
okay uh can it's a directory okay so
we'll
just write this
command we in the home so first we'll
move to
documents sorry
CD
documents and here we will remove the
file that is RM abar 2.txt and now if we
see that has been removed from here and
now we see another command that is nano
and that is also used to create a file
or if you have the exact file what file
name you will enter here which there it
will open that or else it will create a
new file so we'll write abar 3.txt
enter and here you can
directly like edit the file you could
just write the file so you could edit it
here and write
anything that is we are learning
Linux and to save it we'll just press
contrl x y Y and then enter so it has
been
saved we are learning
Linux so this is also the mode to create
a file and you would just go with the
editor directly and you could just enter
in the file and then to save it you just
have to press control x y and
enter and now uh the next command that
is shred command if you want to hide
something or you want don't want to show
any content in a file to anyone so you
will just write or use the shred command
that is shred and after that file name
that
is that is file name obar
3.txt and press enter and we'll use cat
to open
that that
isar 3 do txt and press enter you can
see see that it won't show any content
to
anyone so after that we'll see another
command that is
htop and what does it do is like it's
not found here and it's not installed so
if you want to install
it you could just write this
command that
is
sudo
inall HED toop and press
enter and now it's asking for
password and now mov on to the next
command we will create another window
for that close these
windows close this thumbnail and in this
thumbnail we'll use the command less
and this command is used to view the
contents interactively of the
file so we'll use less and see the
contents of aa. txt press enter so you
could see that the contents are I am a
sir
and see that the content is I
Aisa and
now we will see another
command and for that we'll create a new
window and close the previous
Terminals and in the new terminal we'll
use the GP command that is used to
search for specific patterns or words
within the within the files so GP and
then the special term that is abar will
search and then the file name that is
abisa do txt and press Center so it will
return the full sentence in which that
pattern is found that is I am AAR and
you could see in the file that we have
Aisa text and that is in the line I'm
Aisa and it has returned us that and to
the next command we'll use the find
command and with the find command you
could search for various files or
directories based on a given criteria so
we will find the
a txt file file here and like it has
returned that we are in documents only
and it has returned the abis txt file so
this was about the find command and
moving on to the next command that is to
change file access permissions and that
command is
chmod so missing open uh so we have to
add the open also that is chm O and we
will write
755 and the name of the file that is
abisa do txt and press enter so the
permissions of the file have been
changed
here and what does this indicate so we
have set the file permissions of ab
visa. txt file to read write and execute
for the owner and read and execute for
other sale and if you want to change the
ownership of the file we
will
cut and now moving to the next terminal
and here we will use the command gzip
that is to compress the files so gzip
and then the name of the file that is
a.txt and press enter so it has been
compressed you could see that it has
been compressed and to uncompress or
decompress the compressed files we'll
just write the
command gunzip and then the name of the
file that is
do txt and it has been compressed so the
extension has been changed gz and now if
you see that has been
decompressed so now we will use another
command and now we will see another
command that is date so we'll just write
date and you could see that that date
has been printed and then we have
command who am I and it will just
showcase the current username that is
abisara and the next command is which
and that is to locate a program or
command in the system
path you could just write history to get
all the commands that you have executed
in today's terminal and there another
command that is up time so what does it
indicates is it displays system up time
and load average so system has been up
from which time or how much time so that
is up
time and then there is another command
that is DF that is to display disk space
usage and then we have another command
du that is to display dis usage by file
or
directory so this directory has been
using 12 memories and the next command
is UN
name so un name is used to check the
complete OS information of the system so
we are using Linux here so it has
provided Linux over here and now moving
on to the next
command that is clear command if we use
the clear command so all the things in
the terminal would be cleared so the
next command is man command the man
command displays a user manual for any
command utilities available in the
terminal so we'll just write MN LS and
so these are the commands that are
present in the terminal including the
name description and
options and now moving on to the next
command that is we will use the W get
command to help me download the files
from the internet so for
that if I want to download a YouTube
video just open the Firefox
browser so we just copy the URL from
here and get back to a terminal and use
the command W get and paste the URL
here and press
enter so you could see that it has
downloaded
the file for
us and there's another and we will open
a new terminal for the
command that is shutdown command and for
that you just
outout beat for that you will just write
shutdown space and now and press enter
and the system will be shut down now
only or you could just write shutdown
and the exact time at which time you
want to shut down the system so it will
shut down at that point so these were
the commands for the Linux and that's a
WRA on a top 50 Linux commands remember
the best way to learn is by doing so
open up your terminal and start
experimenting if you found this video
helpful please like subscribe and share
it with your fellow Linux users and drop
a comment below on what Linux topics you
would like to ask for next staying ahead
in your career requires continuous
learning and upskilling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here